Ojo jojo es sieht wirklich verdammt danach
Aus dass kosmologische standardmodell hängt und es sind so stark dass es wahrscheinlich schon bald
erwiesenermaßen ad acta gelegt werden muss ein totaler fail
Wissenschaftler haben jetzt nämlich herausgefunden dass galaxien gar nicht so aufgebaut sind wie das standardmodell
voraussagt und damit existiert auch die dunkle materie nicht und die dunkle energie ist auch gleich mit entsorgt wie konnte das passieren
jetzt den klick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja so sieht es aus wenn die physik grundlegend auf den kopf gestellt wird hier erklären oliver müller und frederico
Laely was sie gefunden haben und das ist mehr als bahnbrechend
er sieht schwer daraus dass das
kosmologische
Standardmodell makulatur ist einfach nicht stimmt dunkle materie und dunkle energie gibt es gar nicht aber der reihe nach
Wie ist denn die physik überhaupt darauf gekommen dass es dunkle materie
Geben könnte in der astrophysik wurde bei galaxien etwas sehr seltsames entdeckt die äußeren arme
drehten sich schneller
Um das zentrum als eigentlich möglich gebe es nur normale materie
würden alle galaxien sofort auseinander fliegen die fliehkraft
Würde sie zerreißen aber was hält sie dann zusammen die erklärung war die dunkle materie wäre sie in einem bestimmten verhältnis
Vorhanden würde sie die galaxien zusammen halten es gäbe
Mehr, dunkle materie als die materie die wir kennen jetzt gab es aber noch ein problem die dunkle materie bildet, zu langsam strukturen
computersimulationen sagen ein viel schnelleres wachstum voraus etwas musste sie abbremsen
Schwupps da war auch schon die dunkle energie da jetzt gibt es aber ein problem mit
Den beiden sie wurden nicht gefunden und in der teilchenphysik gibt es noch nicht einmal irgendwelche
Kandidaten für solche teilchen und jetzt kommt aber eben der hammer alle bisher untersuchten galaxien
entsprechen nicht dem kosmologischen standardmodell noch
Mal langsam zum mitschreiben nicht eigentlich müsste asics zwerggalaxien verstreut um jede galaxie
Geben kugelförmig so sagt es das
kosmologische
standardmodell voraus tun sie aber nicht erst mal sind es nicht ich sondern viel weniger und sie sind nicht verstreut sondern sie liegen auch in
Der ebene der galaxie drehen sich also wie die planeten in unserem sonnensystem in einer ebene um das zentrum
jedenfalls die meisten und das widerspricht dem
kosmologischen standardmodell boom jetzt haben marcel pawlowski oliver müller von ricoh rallye und hell modellieren die galaxie centaurus
A untersucht es ist die dritte galaxie die dem
standardmodell widerspricht viel zugeordnet rotieren hier die zwerggalaxien um die haupt galaxie eben in der rotation ebene von centaurus a
Mit an sicherheit grenzender wahrscheinlichkeit einigkeit ist damit das kosmologische standardmodell widerlegt es müsste schon ein
wahnwitziger zufall sein wenn schon die dritte galaxie
Zufällig etwas besonderes wäre es spricht also vieles wenn nicht alles dafür dass das
kosmologische standardmodell so nicht funktioniert falsch ist eine nie
Bewiesene hypothese jetzt auch widerlegt wurde denn das ist ihr wichtig dieses standard wurde war bisher eine
Hypothese die es zu beweisen galt was jetzt wiederum nicht gelungen ist und die menge der in diez sind die jetzt dagegen
Sprechen die werden immer erdrückender für pavel kroupa von der universität bonn und doktorvater von pawlowski ist alles klar zitat
wir erleben ein
Wissenschaftliches erdbeben er sieht die dunkle materie damit als widerlegt und mahnt eine reform
Des gravitationsgesetz anja das ist der absolute wahnsinn aber was ist es das die galaxien zusammenhält
Ich hatte ja schon mal über schwarze löcher spekuliert die sehr viel mehr
geben soll als bisher gedacht oder gestern die kosmischen strings die ja offensichtlich
Unglaubliche mengen an masse enthalten es wird also bald ziemlich
Spannend wenn dieses rätsel gelöst wird wenn er als erstes neues zu diesem thema und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei
Whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom neuesten video also vorab garantiert ihr könnt dann
direkt in der redaktion folglich zum mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder
andere ideen der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür
draufklicken dunkle materie rätsel löst spielen schwarze löcher eine rolle ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran